en el día de acción global por un aborto
libre y seguro en américa latina chile
tiene razones para celebrar la cámara de
diputados aprobó un proyecto de ley para
despenalizar el aborto a las 14 semanas
de gestación por 75 votos a favor 68 en
contra y 2 abstenciones
esto es un primer primerísimo paso de
ahí el proyecto todavía tendría que ir a
una comisión de mujer que ya lo rechazó
ver si se puede legislar en detalle
volver a la cámara de diputados- y de
ser aprobado ahí todavía llegar al
senado será seguro un largo caminos no
sin reveses en un país en el que este
tema enfrenta sectores de la sociedad y
que es muy opuesto por las partes más
conservadoras del país en este día se
producían manifestaciones en torno al ex
congreso por parte de asociaciones
feministas que pedían precisamente el
aborto libre en el país y también
amnistía internacional entregaba un
informe que habla de los problemas que
encuentran las mujeres que tratan de
ejercer su derecho al aborto terapeútico
en tres causales violación riesgo de la
vida del feto riesgo de la vida de la
madre aunque esta ley fue aprobada en el
segundo mandato de michelle bachelet
todavía son muchas las mujeres que
encuentran problemas
la hora de llevarla a la práctica en
chiles se realizan entre 30.000 y
120.000 abortos según cifras no
oficiales